I think we should do a game show and
remember before I say this I am kidding
I'm saying it because it's so stupid
that would be like this is a bit what if
there was a game show where we got
racist white men and had them fist fight
illegal aliens the illegal alien no
matter what country they're from
whatever race you want it to be in your
head is your is what race it is okay
racist white man fighting illegal alien
if the legal alien wins he gets
citizenship and some money if the racist
white man wins he gets a mill
but if the racist white man loses he has
to leave America forever
you [__] you got that loaded up they
don't know what race they think we're
gonna get a little a Juan from Oaxaca
6'3 from the Congo that will crush your
skull
[Applause]